pull-up ninjas outfit at the game awards
oh the the camo yeah here's the thing if
you google ninja outfit you just you get
some good ass [ __ ] you really know how
it was you get it's a put gamer
oh man got that [ __ ] Soviet cam over
it it is straight from the USSR brother
that camo is crazy old dude looking like
[ __ ] dude this [ __ ] looks like
baloney with mold on it yeah it really
does it's like a moldy it looks like
camo that's gone bad who is your style
is bruh fire them yeah Oh on God you in
the hair on top of on top of that it
just doesn't just makes it so bad is
this like a this is just like an awful
prom outfit yeah it really is dude but
yeah but you know he probably didn't go
so props for him for doing
you're not surprising go all white all
white suit is like I mean that would
have looked fine with the blue hair yeah
true
it actually would look pretty hard yeah
it will look fresh better than this yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] moldy baloney can
they're gonna put this colorway on an
off-white and just call it off white
moldy Bologna Bologna deli meat deli
meat this is brutal
it's like a Christmas tree with ham hung
on the as ornaments I just can't get
over how much it looks like him like
that's the problem with the suit is you
should never look at a suit and get the
vibe that is actually ham you know yeah
yeah yeah like I see the suit and I
don't think it's clothes I think I
really think it's food like someone's
just standing there chucking is a deli
meat
landing on that one also looks like a
dick sort of Oh most definitely
on the left yeah that one's pretty
phallic yeah I got the ball sack right
there and then arts like you know that
could even be the head you know that's
coming off of an appendage the camel
doesn't make sense bro cuz cuz camo but
also why why black underneath yeah the
black shirt and black tie well yeah it
just doesn't work at all to me yeah cuz
usually the the black is blended in
right oops even if you go with like
digital camo print right that's like
pretty crazy
I even like it's just like this there's
there is an aesthetic mm-hmm there's
like purpose I mean not that I've like
ever watched the video on YouTube
explaining like the history of digital
camo that I've ever done that or like
the purpose but like what why is this
the bottom left so big with no pattern
that's that's the that's the issue is
it's not camo it's not camo at all I
let's just splotchy we just assumed it
was camel so that's that's where the
designer is gonna call us tiny-brained
does that were idiots and we just saw
camo but also it's not camo yeah what is
it then yeah it's it's I don't know it's
baloney that's for sure yeah
you